inflation in the united states just hit
9.1 percent it's a 40-year high and the
folks over on the all-in podcast we're
recently talking about has inflation
peaked or should we expect higher and
higher inflation in the coming months
chemoth palopatia had a great point
saying that a huge piece of the
inflation calculation comes from rent
and rent doesn't show up for a few
months he also pointed out that he
believes that inflation over nine
percent was a possibility and could even
see it going slightly higher but his big
takeaway was that we are in a sustained
inflationary environment here's what
chamoth had to say on the podcast you
know we talked about this that this was
going to be a big print right i think we
all expected this to be a big print i
actually also kind of put myself on a
limb there and i said you know i
wouldn't be surprised if at some point
we print a mid to high nines maybe even
a 10 handle at some point we're getting
there and the reason is because rents
are a little
you know uh they lag in how
they're reported inside of cpi so we
have a couple more months to go of of
rents and rents are moving or budging a
bit that's number one um we do see a
little bit of fall off in in energy
prices but i'm not so sure that it's
it's enough frankly to to move the
needle so i think that we could be in a
sustained period for a while after this
inflation print the expectation for july
went to 80 basis points from 75 which
means a small percentage of people
actually think it's going to be 100
and
september i think moved to 75. so the
question is is that enough i just don't
know i'm worried that we're in a
sustained inflationary environment i'm
worried about that i i hope that we're
not
now i tend to agree with chamoth but the
hard part about a lot of this
conversation is how do you define
sustained inflationary environment how
do you define whether inflation is
transitory or not there is no clear
definition what we know is that for the
last 12 months the united states economy
has experienced inflation over 5 percent
that alone i think proves that inflation
was not transitory and also that we are
in a sustained inflationary environment
the big question is how high can we go
we're at 9.1 percent now could we see
9.5 10 or higher no one knows the other
question is how long will this go on for
will this be a six month exercise 12
months 18 24 or longer the federal
reserve they understand the high
inflation has to come down and they're
doing everything in their power to get
it down they're raising interest rates
as aggressively as they can and they're
going ahead and trying to conduct
quantitative tightening by selling
assets off their balance sheet but at
the end of the day we are in a high
inflation environment no one knows how
high it can go and no one knows how long
it can last but a sustained inflationary
environment is not something that many
people were talking about or predicting
in january of 2020 fast forward two and
a half years later and here we are we
can look around the world for examples
of what happens in these situations if
you go to a place like argentina what
you see is things like price controls
and we've also seen here in the united
states many politicians talk about price
gouging or potential price controls now
i hope for the good of the people that
we don't actually get price controls
that we get inflation to come down and
that the federal reserve can navigate
this tough time without actually pushing
us into a recession it's a lot of ifs
and this is a highly complex situation
but i know that the people on the ground
the average american family they're
struggling right now seeing things like
9.1 percent official inflation is a bad
bad number and if it gets worse that
means there's only more pain to come the
solution hopefully won't be worse than
the problem but right now that problem
is eating away at the savings and wealth
of millions and millions of americans
and it is destroying the hard work and
economic value that those families have
put forward over the last few years
inflation hurts the average person and
we got to get it down 9.1 percent is a
crazy number but i'm with chamoth we're
in a sustained inflationary environment
how high it goes how long it lasts no
one knows
but we must act more aggressively to get
this down
because if not
we may just repeat the mistakes of other
countries that have had to endure
double-digit inflation for sustained
periods of time